This is episode two of The Synthetic Signal, and like episode one it is completely fabricated.
Ada Kestrel here with Milo Vance. Every company, price and statistic in this episode was invented for a software demo.
Northwind Logistics reported an invented eleven percent drop in spot freight rates this quarter.
Spot rates are what you pay when you did not book ahead, which in this made-up market is most of the time.
The invented CPI print for the quarter came in at two point four percent.
Milo, does a fictional CPI print tell you anything at all about fictional freight?
Not directly. Fuel is a much bigger input than the CPI basket we invented would suggest.
Our made-up GDP figure grew one point one percent, which in this fantasy counts as a soft landing.
Harbour Robotics turns up here too, because Northwind Logistics is a fictional customer of theirs.
They bought two hundred imaginary picking arms and claim a thirty percent throughput gain.
A claim like that is exactly the kind of thing you want a timestamp attached to.
Meridian Grid, our invented utility, raised overnight power prices again in this storyline.
That pushes Northwind Logistics towards daytime charging, which collides with their invented delivery windows.
The AI scheduling system they lease is supposed to solve exactly that, in this fiction.
It costs them a fictional nineteen dollars per GPU hour, billed monthly, and it is not clear it earns that back.
That is the show. None of it is real, none of it is advice, and all of it carries a timestamp you can check.